Thanks so I'd like to thank the
organizers for the invitation to speak
here I should mention that my talk is
probably one of the few outliers in this
workshop in the sense that it has
nothing to do with complexity although
you know there might be some downstream
connections okay so this is based on
joint work with the number of people
whom I will and I will mention the
relevant papers as we go along but those
people include Adam Marcus Prasad Italy
Anjali Jo Julio Wang and yeah nice
country honest so so just to outline the
talk I'll start out with some background
and motivations for thinking about the
connections between entropy inequalities
and additive combinatorics and then I'll
discuss one basic question which we can
actually treat in considerable
generality so in the general setting of
locally compact abelian groups and
that's the question of how the entropy
of a sum of two independent random
variables is related to the difference I
mean the entropy of the difference and
then I mean that's really and then
that's really an example question there
are there are many other things that can
be said but this is one question that we
will isolate in order to you know make
the exposition reasonable but then we
will look at phenomena that arise for
particular groups and although I
mentioned three settings here are n the
integers and D mod PZ I will focus only
on the integers today so some broad
motivation I don't think I need to
introduce additive combinatorics for
people here I'm sure people have seen it
in some avatar or the other but for
instance results like Samara Dee's
theorem which guarantees the existence
of arithmetic progressions of arbitrary
length for subsets of the integers that
have positive upper density and so on
are classical results in additive
combinatorics and generally speaking
additive combinatorics has to do with
looking not not just I mean if you look
at the origins of additive combinatorics
it probably comes from
number theory but questions where it was
not just questions involving the
multiplicative structure so prime
factorization for instance but additive
structure things like additive
arithmetic progressions and so on but
from those origins one can ask questions
about additive structure and more
general groups not necessarily the
integers and now there is a rich theory
that has been developed you know and you
know the book of tau and Wu for example
consolidates a lot of this theory with
with applications to many different
areas but in any case one of the sets of
tools that are very useful in additive
combinatorics are so-called some set
inequalities so what are these when we
talk about a sum set this is really just
the Minkowski sum if you if you take two
sets a and B and you have a group
operation so a and B are subsets of some
group and you have a group operation
plus then a plus B is the set of all
pairwise sums that you get by taking
elements from a and elements from B okay
so a some set inequality is some
inequality that relates the
cardinalities of various some sets so
for example here are some classical some
set inequalities from you know from from
developed by blue NECA and Russia for
example so so Russia's triangle
inequality relates the cardinality of
the different set a minus C to the
difference sets a minus B B minus C and
the set B so the different set is
defined in exactly the same way as the
Sun set right so a minus C is just the
set of little a minus little see their
little a's and capital a and lists the
season capital c and so on and then
there is there some difference in
equality which relates the cardinality
of the sum of two sets to the
cardinality of difference of two sets
okay so so these kinds of inequalities
you can ask if they hold in for finite
subsets of any group and you know so for
example these these these turn out to be
facts for finite subsets of the integers
okay but these these kinds of
inequalities so so some set inequalities
of this type
often not sharp and and they hold in
considerable generality but you can but
you can also look for sharp inequalities
so for example the Cauchy Davenport
inequality actually I'm cheating the
Cauchy Davenport inequality is this
statement for ZMOT easy but let's just
look at the integers says that if you
have finite subset so three integers
then the cardinality of the sunset is at
least the sum of the cardinality is -1
with equality if and only if the two
sets are at of arithmetic progressions
so this is actually very easy to see
right because if you have two subsets of
the integers you know the nice thing
about the integers is that is that it's
an ordered set so if you have a set so
first of all cardinality is not affected
by translation right so you can
translate both the sets a and B to start
at 0 for instance and then you have a
bunch of elements of a starting at 0 and
another bunch of elements of B and if
you just look at let's say the smallest
you know you order these and then you
look at let's say a 0 plus all the
elements of B and and then you look at
the largest element of B whatever that
is plus you know the other elements of a
you end up with a set that is ordered of
cardinality mod a plus mod B minus 1 so
so so this is really a an elementary
observation sorry yes yes yeah yeah here
for equality you need the common
difference to be the same thank you yeah
okay so so but one can ask about
stability of these kinds of inequalities
so for example suppose you know that the
size of a plus a so what this tells you
is that the size of a plus a which by
the way is not the same as 2a right it's
not just the it's not just every element
of a multiplied by 2 because you can
have distinct elements being added so so
so if the size of a plus a is not too
large relative to the size of a right so
let's say it's bounded by some factor K
times the size of a then
Fryman theorem for instance guarantees
that a is closed in some sense to some
generalized version of an
matic progression right so this is a
very very powerful theorem which has
many applications including two random
matrices and many other areas but but in
any case so so so so that's some of the
classical theory but what's the
connection of the entropy well the the
there's a connection between
cardinalities and entropy is as long
known so for instance and has been used
in combinatoric for a long time so for
instance you know if we denote by
capital H the Shannon entropy in the in
the discrete setting then we know that
the entropy of the uniform distribution
on a finite set is just the log of the
cardinality of that set and this
connection has been used quite a bit so
probably starting with Shearer's lemma
and then Jai Kumar's proof of fragments
theorem and then many other ways in
which entropy has been used for counting
problems for example by Jeff Kahn and
who treat good and others so so in any
case a few years ago
Umbra Russia you know suggested that
perhaps some of these entropy
inequalities would also be useful in
additive combinatorics and he he proved
some results and formulated some
conjectures and subsequently there's
been a bunch of work so so in particular
in in the sort of direct inequalities
possibly lose that I mentioned you know
so the this paper of Russia paper with
Adam Marcus and prasat Italy are papers
of that type and then if you want to
look for sharp inequalities than a paper
of jog and an anti ROM or this this
paper of Tao and in the paper with bang
and vu treat those kinds of inequalities
so so what's our goal so our goal is to
is to continue this development of an
entropy theory in additive combinatorics
and we want to focus both on phenomena
that are independent of the group you
are looking at and on phenomena which
care about the group so there are many
motivations for this so in so so our
original motivation actually came from
probability so
it turns out that these kinds of
inequalities entropy inequalities are
related to basic questions in
probability like the rate of convergence
in the entropic central limit theorem
which I won't have time to get further
into that connection but but also
there's applications to additive
combinatorics to convex geometry to
information theory
so in particular some of these
inequalities have been used by mu Shama
and were due to improve our
understanding of the degrees of freedom
of the interference channel and so on
this is a classical communication
problem so so anyway let me jump into it
with just one just a little bit about
notation so that the discrete entropy is
something that is familiar to everyone
here we've been talking about it all
week but but there's also a notion of
continuous entropy so if you look at a
random variable X which has some density
little F on RN then you can talk about
the differential entropy which is just
minus the integral of F log F and this
is of course just the analog of the Shia
discrete entropy if you replace the Sun
by an integral and probability mass
function by a density function but now
things change a lot because this entropy
need not be non-negative anymore and so
on but in any case you can also talk
about relative entropy and that's always
non-negative so that still gives you
some you know some nice properties but
but in any case what I want to just
mention without spending too much time
on this is that one can use the
following unified setting so as long as
one has a locally compact group then you
are guaranteed a hard measure which is a
translation invariant measure and as
long as you define the entropy as minus
the integral of F log F where you look
at densities with respect to the hard
measure this captures both you know
discrete entropy for for example for the
integers or whatever and the
differential entropy and it generalizes
it to general locally compact groups and
so so I mean that's a I just want to say
that to make the point that you know
some of these results can be stated in
the general setting of locally compact
abelian group
and then we are measuring the entropy
with respect to this hard measure on the
group so but you know it's a 4/4 for all
practical purposes if you focus on the
integers and the real line that's
sufficient for now okay so so so here is
one basic question
so suppose Y and y prime are iid random
variables taking values in some group G
and when I said density F you can you
can replace that by probability mass
function if you are thinking about the
discrete setting so so then the question
is just this how different can the
entropy of y plus y prime and the
entropy of Y minus y prime be okay this
seems like a pretty fundamental question
right you add two independent random
variables or you take the difference how
different can the entropies be well of
course if if Y has a symmetric
distribution in the sense that it's its
mass function or density is symmetric
about the identity in the group then y
plus y prime has the same distribution
as Y minus y Prime and the entropies are
not different so this is really
capturing something about how asymmetric
a probability distribution on a group
can be and so here is one answer if you
take G being either the group of the
integers or the group of the real
numbers the entropies of the sum and
difference can differ by an arbitrarily
large amount okay so in other words
given any M positive there exists iid
random variables Y and Y prime of finite
entropy such that the difference between
the entropy of the difference and the
entropy of the sum is greater than M and
this goes both ways so so one one way is
do to lop it off and Pete and the other
way is due to our be emanuel Abed young
AV and us so so so yeah okay so I'll
mention that in a minute so so yeah I
mean one can prove them in a somewhat
unified way but there is a difference
between them and the difference between
them is because you know a priori you
you do not expect it is not even clear
if there should exist random variables
such that the entropy of the
some should be greater than the entropy
of the difference in in general you
would so even four sets for example it
was not known until the 60s whether
there is a subset of the integers such
that the size of the some set is bigger
than the size of the different set this
was a question this was a combinatorial
question which was solved by Conway he
came up with the first examples of
so-called more sums than differences
sets okay because the thing is if you if
you look at differences right it's
throwing out points on both sides
because the different set is symmetric
right the some set is not and so so in
general you might expect the size of a -
A to B to be bigger but but but yeah it
turns out it's not always bigger
although they're rare much rarer to find
okay but but in any case it turns out
that so so that's why that's why I
bothered to stress the if the fact that
we have two two answers here but in any
case yeah I mean there is a way that you
can sort of prove these in a at least by
unified proof strategy but but perhaps
the easiest way to prove this doesn't
work for this which is which might be
more challenging because this is saying
that the entropy of the sum can be
arbitrarily larger yes so the idea here
is to first do it for the integers and
then you can use some approximation
arguments to do it for the real line
I know that yeah they're IRD no because
for for example are the integers you
don't have a nice scaling right on the
real line you can do that on the real
line if you have you have scaling right
if you look at the entropy of a times a
random variable some scalar times a
random variable that's actually entropy
of the random variable plus log a so you
have a scaling which can allow you to
change the entropy but in the discrete
case you can't do that right so and
exactly and differences wants a 1 scale
anyway because once once you look at the
difference between these two entropy is
the scaling won't matter anyway this is
an affine invariant
what do you mean by do everything I mean
ok so so there are ok I'm not sure
actually about the answer to this
question but well you definitely can't
realize everything because there are
going to be some natural constraints
just coming from elementary entropy
inequalities right entropy of the sum
and the difference the joint entropy in
the discrete setting for instance is
going to be bounded by the entropy of Y
and Y prime just by the data processing
inequality if you like ok yeah so then I
then yeah yeah yeah then sure if you if
you are just saying is any is any point
in the plane achievable as for some
distribution yes the answer is yes
okay so anyway so so for example so this
is you know that the fact that we can do
this for the integers is not so obvious
because for example if you look at Z mod
3z we can prove that the entropy of the
difference is always bigger than the
entropy of the Sun okay so any
distribution Z mod 3z is simple right
yeah well this is this but this is
already non trivial to prove I mean it's
it's an exercise to prove this you know
so so but anyway you can prove this and
we don't know what the answer is for
example for Z mod for Z or Z mod 5 Z
right we believe that there is there is
some threshold such that you know for
example we know that once you go to Z
mod 29 Z right which is which is what
you would need to be able to use this
integer example in a in a cyclic in a
finite cyclic group you would need Z mod
29 Z once you go to Z mod 29 z that
exists random variables such that the
entropy if the sum can be bigger than
the entropy of the difference but in
between Z mod 3 Z and Z ma 29z we don't
know right
so anyway okay so here's the second
answer though which might you know which
complements the first answer yes okay so
so for for for discrete random variables
you can achieve any point in the
positive quadrant for continuous random
variables you have other things that
come into play
yes okay so okay so right so so here's
the second answer to the same question
so again we are asking how different can
the entropy of y plus y Prime and
entropy of Y minus y prime be well it
turns out that if you look at these you
know well if you if you look at these
entropy s and you normalize them by
subtracting off the entropy of Y
in the first place then the ratio
between these two quantities has to lie
between half and two okay so in this
sense these two entropy s cannot be too
different right so so let's let's
interpret this result so what this is
saying is that if you look at the
entropy increases for addition and
subtraction let entropy always increases
when you add an independent random
variable look at how much it increases
for addition and for subtraction then
our first result are the first answer is
stating that the difference between
these entropy increases Delta plus -
Delta - can be arbitrarily large but the
second answer is saying that the ratio
must always between ha almost lie
between 1/2 and - ok and one thing about
this result is that this result actually
holds for any locally compact abelian
group not just for the integers of the
real line so for any locally compact
abelian group we have that this result
holds so okay so for discrete groups for
discrete random variables half of this
result was due to independently to
Russia and tau and Russia conjectured
the other half and that was proved with
Marcus and totally but it turns out that
the the discrete proofs do not
necessarily generalize you know
immediately to the continuous setting
because the discrete setting you have
all these additional properties like non
negativity of entropy and you know
preservation of entropy and taking by
ejective mappings which completely fail
when you're when you go to the
continuous setting so so you need some
additional things to do this in the
general locally compact abelian case but
it turns out you can you can you can do
it so ok so how much time do I have
five minutes okay then I'm not going to
say anything about the proof but I'll
try to say about the second class of
results so phenomena that arise for
particular groups so all you need to
look at in this slide is the definitions
of Raney entropy so there there is one
parameter family of generalizations of
entropy right of Shannon entropy which
is there any entropies this is what is
usually called the mean entropy and then
anyway so but yeah the other entropy of
interest would be there any entropy of
order zero which is just the log of the
support size of a distribution P right
so okay the reason I say this is because
all right so okay so one can ask okay so
so on the real line you know questions
about sharp lower bounds for the entropy
of a sum of independent things are very
important for many reasons this is the
so called entropy power inequality due
to Shannon and Stan and I don't have
time to go into those reasons or why
this why this inequality has this form
and so on
but-but-but-but motivated by this one
might expect that you know that that
inequality is for the integers for
instance so is there some discrete
analogue of these sharp lower bounds for
the entropy of a sum and for for example
Towe proved this result which is
asymptotically sharp if X and X prime
are iid integer valued random variables
actually for integer valued random
variables then the entropy of X plus X
prime minus the entropy of X is at least
half log 2 minus something that's little
o of 1 as the entropy of X goes to
infinity okay but this is an asymptotic
result one would like results that are
known as emphatic so it's there there
exist such results for example due to
rajeshwar RB and pelipper
but this result is not sharp okay so so
what one would like sharp results that
are non asymptotic and from that point
of view so so we can say something in
this direction but yeah so maybe I'll
just jump ahead ok so so here is here is
one discrete analogue of the entropy
power inequality so what it says is that
if you if you look at
integer valued random variables right
X&Y are integer valued then the entropy
of X plus and these are independent then
the entropy of X plus y is at least the
entropy of X plus plus y star ok so I I
need to define what this X plus and y
star are but these are basically
discrete kinds of rearrangements so you
look at the probability mass function of
X or the probability mass function of Y
and then you you want to rearrange these
in a way that is somehow the probability
mass function is approximately symmetric
and decreasing away from the origin ok
so if you so there are there are
continuous versions of this this
inequality by the way which which
involve spherically symmetric decreasing
rearrangements of densities on RN but
you can't quite do that on the integers
right because you don't want to break up
masses right so if you don't want to
break up masses then you have multiple
ways of rearranging mass on the integers
you know you can put the biggest mass at
zero but then the second biggest mass
you have to decide whether you want to
put it on plus 1 or minus 1 ok so
whether you privileged the positive side
or the negative side you get two
different notions of rearrangement so
that's where this plus comes from but in
any case it as it is a there's an
assumption here as well which I okay so
so this this inequality only holds if
one of the random variables say Y has
the property that its rearrangement on
the plus side is the same as the
rearrangement on the minus side so that
that imposes a kind of regularity
property on the distribution of Y a
regularity assumption but but in any
case under that assumption this this
inequality turns out to be true and it
turns its it so happens that this is not
just true for Shannon entropy but the
same inequality is true for any entropy
of arbitrary order ok so as a corollary
of this again I'm going to have to rush
through this ok this this picture might
help explain the rearrangements at least
so you have some probability mass
function here here is the is the
plus-side rearrangement you put the
largest mass at 0 the second largest at
1 third largest minus 1 and so on this
is the you know the the opposite
rearrangement and then let's ignore this
for now but in any case
right so so so so the result that I
mentioned holds true for arbitrary Denny
entropies this is written in a different
notation I apologize this is written you
know this should be X plus y if you're
thinking of the random variables but in
any case one implication of this is that
you can recover as R goes to zero you
recover something like the Koshi
Davenport inequality whereas for R
equals one you have an entropy
inequality and so on so you get a whole
one parameter family of these these
inequalities which in particular
recovers gosh I haven't put so for the
integers at least so so anyway so it
turns out so maybe I'll just mention one
more thing which is close before closing
which is that no let me not so yeah so
so there's this emerging entropy theory
of additive combinatorics where some
very general statements can be made for
locally compact abelian groups like the
statements about sum and difference but
but also you know they I think it would
be interesting to look for other sharp
inequalities that can be developed for
specific groups and although I haven't
talked much about it there are
applications of this theory in various
areas to Thanks yes feedbacks
so okay so in in the discrete case yes
you can you can prove that so so as a
consequence I mean okay so so this is a
few fix
right so in the discrete case you can
prove I think actually I didn't mention
this but but you can prove that this
ratio actually lies between 3/4 and 4/3
ok but but one way to prove that is to
is to use our result so so so we have
this general result which which works
for arbitrarily locally compact abelian
groups that this difference the Delta
plus divided by Delta minus is between
half and two and if you just if you just
manipulate this and use the fact that n
trapeze are non-negative you basically
get this fact so it's it's finer somehow
then just that fact sorry oh you're
right
yeah yeah sorry yeah sorry you know I
was I was mistake I was I was miss
thinking yes yeah you're right yeah
what's right
no no this is not sharp so so yeah there
should be there should be there should
be other constraints sorry yeah the
thing is that are there you know
depending on what you decide to fix and
what you decide to leave free there are
many different have years you can get so
yeah I'm sorry I misspoke yeah in your
inequality over there the one that's age
of y plus y 5 minus H of Y okay so that
was when y and y prime are identically
independent yes okay so we have results
in that case but so they're more
complicated to state so I I think in
that case you get something like that
okay then then then you know you get
results involving and all for entropy is
right you have entropy of X plus y
entropy of X minus y entropy of X and
entropy of Y and then you so so so you
can prove that that there's for example
I think if you look at let's say a
symmetric version so you look at
something like this now I'm going by
memory this I might be mistaking exactly
what this is but this is something like
this okay so and if you look at the
corresponding thing for entropy of X
minus y normalized in the same way then
I think what you get is factor of three
three and one-third okay in the general
general iid case is this ratio that I
can point you to the relevant result in
our paper yes if you go back to the
expression you had there where you it's
a nice immature asymmetric expression
because the you have each of Y the one
that you have originally got is that are
there examples where it's unbounded
if you don't have identical
distributions I would expect so yeah I'm
not sure I haven't checked but I would
expect so I don't see any reason for it